[Music]
um
[Music]
i guess how to get like a data driven
learning based approach to work on real
robots
i don't know i mean i guess like agi is
one of these things that's like
if you did solve it it would be truly a
landmark i guess in my field that that
is sort of the
absolute holy grail and people have
theorems that show that
you know these kinds of agi systems
might even exist in certain ways
and but others debate it others say that
you might never get an agi system but i
think that's something along those lines
at least in the field of machine
learning would be like one of the the
greatest unsolved problems that you
could tackle
my interests often fall into
places where technology and
humans interact and have overlap
and i think that this is going to be
true regardless of
where and when we are but um creating
equitable spaces
in technology
that kind of do minimal harm
and give people voices i think that
across the board that's very difficult
um
the current place that we see that the
most right now i think is in machine
learning so machine learning and
fairness is really really
hot um but there are other places where
that's true if you think about just user
experiences if you think about your
iphone you know the needs of someone who
is much older who's like in a geriatric
facility for example are significant and
significantly different than what a
someone in their 20s or 40s or 50s i
think one of the most important unsolved
problems but also possibly unsolvable
problems
is figuring out
how to get machines to better interact
with humans
or how to develop
the machinery to understand how humans
will interact with
machines or algorithms i think that you
know we're starting to use incredibly
complicated systems all over the place
and
to me the complicated problem is the
integration of these you know complex
systems that have bugs and problems
with human beings because humans
ultimately are the ones who are using
the code and making decisions based off
of you know the
recommendations that the code gives them
and i think thinking about how code
interacts with people uh is just like
such a an open question
so when i think of this question in
terms of the hot topics these days you
know machine learning and artificial
intelligence
most of the stuff is limited by
art capabilities as humans because
especially for supervised learning
methods
we need to provide some sort of data set
and that say the data set is usually
labeled by humans so if you want to go
beyond that and explore
intelligence beyond human intelligence
then we need to think about
new ways different ways that we might
not even be able to perceive so i think
that's going to be the next challenge
in the next decades
understanding when your model is no
longer going to work before seeing
labels for that is is i think incredibly
important we have lots of tools to say
if i know this like let's see the data
comes from out of this kind of machine
make the model work well given that data
but what happens in the wild with its
arbitrarily changed is still very hard
to understand
and i think it's a key bonding to really
making intelligent systems like society
scale
so like safe ml i think is still open
fun challenge
yeah i think what's interesting in my
particular field which is about how to
make robots is that there isn't
there isn't really one existing problem
that everyone is trying to solve it's
more that people are
trying to figure out new problems to
define and then proceed to solve them
that way
[Music]
you